if we get a number one scar pattern Star
Trek factual it would be around about a
million dollars did you know that the
most expensive AK-47 skin in CS go
hasn't actually been unboxed yet what
bro what are you talking about man now I
know what you're thinking what about the
case hardened with the four Titan
katowice 2014 Hollows that sold for 150k
last year sure that's the most anyone's
paid for an AK skin so far but the
Majestic highly elusive true blue Gem of
AK skins a factory new stat track
case-hardened blue gem pattern number
661 still hasn't been found odds are
definitely not in a favor we can dream
one day though someone will unbox one of
these Beauties hell some people have
made it their life's mission to track
one of these skins down China is
actively trying to hunt it if we get a
number one scar pattern Star Trek
faction it would be around about a
million dollars round about a million
dollars if you hit it